[Music]
it's me walking up Saddam on all fours
as easy as walking on two feet not scary
or frightening to me in the least
I've always been flexible but not just a
little bit flexible I'm I'm really
flexible little did I know that
disability was in fact a talent that had
changed my life completely
[Music]
I'm Troy James and I'm a creature actor
I play creatures on TV and movies that
move in ways that make the audience
squirt my talent is that all of my
joints my legs my arms my shoulders my
fingers they just bend however I want
them to so if you need an alien demon or
a nonhuman creature that doesn't move in
ways that normal human people do that's
when you call me it looks like what I do
is extremely painful really it doesn't
hurt at all I don't know why I am as
flexible as I am it's just something I
was born with I'm the only one in my
family who can bend this arms and legs
the way I do I didn't think it was that
strange until other kids told me it was
but they weren't very nice about it and
I remember being very embarrassed and I
hid it away because what makes you
different when you're growing up isn't
something to be proud of I hid it for a
long time but that all changed when I
got a job as an amusement park ride
operator it was a hot day the ride was
down for some reason or another the
guests were getting kind of ornery and I
thought why don't I show them what I
could do and I went up and down the line
making really cool shapes with my body
and it was a hit
and that was the first time I gotten
that sort of positive reaction from
other people showcasing my talent I
never thought my ability was anything
more than a really cool party trick my
friend put his camera up to me and said
show me something cool then he posted it
on the Internet and all of a sudden my
phone started ringing I started getting
calls to be cast in TV shows and I
didn't look back if you had told me a
year ago I was going to be an actor I
would have laughed at you but after some
of my performances people have told me
that it's not just the way out of my
body that's effective it's the acting
behind it I bring a reaction of the
audience I can throw them so to speak
coming from a place where you were
ostracized as I was as a child I can
bring that out as a creature it's
interesting that something that I hid
for so long is now taking me places that
I never imagined I would go I believe
everyone has a superpower and you may
not know it's a superpower but if it's
something that you're passionate about
makes it happy I think sharing it with
the world may not be such a bad idea
after all
[Music]
you